MIT OpenCourseWare is a
free and open publication
of material from
thousands of MIT courses
covering the entire
MIT curriculum
and used by millions of learners
and educators around the world.
OCW Educator is a faculty
inspired initiative
to share teaching
approaches and materials
from MIT with educators
everywhere, for free.
Instructors share their
instructional insights
via discourse at MIT sections of
their OCW course publications.
These sections illustrate how
the course was taught on campus
and include a course overview,
course outcomes, curriculum
information,
student demographics
and personal interviews
with faculty about how
they taught the course.
Many MIT instructors share a
variety of teaching materials
with educators,
including resources
like lecture notes, video
lectures, exams and assignments
and special elements,
like demonstrations.
These materials, like
all materials on OCW,
are made for sharing.
Download files for later, share
with students, modify, remix
and reuse in your teaching.
Just remember to cite
OCW as the source.
OCW Educator is now
making it easier
to find the teaching materials
and instructional insights you
need, faster.
Use the finder on the
OCW Educator portal
to search for resources.
You can search by
instructional approach.
Or you can search for teaching
materials by subject area.
You could also use the
OCW Educator portal
to find other resources
like, OCW courses
about teaching and education.
Or pedagogy highlights and
course introduction videos.
Or more information about
what inspired MIT faculty
to begin the OCW
Educator initiative.
We're excited about
this and we welcome
you to start using and
sharing OCW Educator.